what's up everyone we are here from e3
2016 I'm Mike McCarty and Scott
Butterworth hello you've got the chance
to play a game we've known about for a
long time a long time The Last Guardian
Last Guardian it's been what eight years
since we first heard the announcement
way too long yeah and so now not only
did to play it it has like an actual
release date it's a real game now it's
finally a real game so initial thoughts
what do you think how long was a demo uh
demo was actually a good like 45 minutes
oh wow it was a pretty significant chunk
of the game and it's actually like it
starts at the very beginning of the game
at least from what I can tell I mean
it's in terms of the narrative framing
it seems very much like we're at the
beginning of the story so it actually
opens with the unnamed boy waking up in
a cave next to Trico and a narrator's
voice comes on it says like I you know I
woke up and I had no idea how I got
there were these strange markings on my
body and it's become very apparent that
it's actually like an older version of
the boy narrating the experience cuz
he's got this like deep kind of gruff
voice so I mean some people I think
we're speculating that either the boy or
trico is gonna die parently the boy
doesn't die because he's the one they're
reading the whole game so like totally
does it seem like the kind of game where
there might be death involved
potentially I mean it has kind of this
like somber whimsical tone there's a
very stirring soundtrack layered
underneath everything that's happening
it's you know the whole the whole
experience seems like it's built around
the empathy that you're developing
between Trico and the boy I mean it's
really fascinating watching them
interacting Trico is so believable I
mean anybody that's owned a dog or a cat
you'll see these little little pieces of
behavior that reminds you so much of a
real animal like he'll you know
something will fall in front of a little
kind of recoil a little bit or you'll
hear them kind of whimper when you start
to walk away from him like it's it's
really believable and it creates kind of
a strong bond very quickly and the boy
is actually really interesting as well I
mean typically when you think of a
protagonist in a game you're thinking of
like you know someone who's kind of
powerful who's gonna be able to like
drive you through the experience but the
boy is the exact opposite Hughes
portrayed as vulnerable right from the
very beginning and everything about his
body language is like wood anytime he
tries to lift something he has to
struggle to do it every time he's
dangling from a Ledge he's close like
scrambling to pull himself up like
everything about the game implies that
he's very vulnerable and very
which is reliant on trico to kind of
keep them alive so what kind of other
gameplay scenarios did you see whether
they're a lot during the demo no it's
it's very light on mechanics which is
which is kind of true of you know I mean
anybody played shadows it's out of the
Colossus kind of knows that you know
it's not so much about having this huge
array of mechanics it's sort of how you
use those mechanics um so most of stuff
that I played at least in this very
early portion of the game was you know
very light platforming which actually
worked in an interesting way there's
both a jump and a grab button and so in
order to climb up ledges and stuff you
have to time it so that you jump it and
grab the ledge that's kind of totally
yeah and you can of course climb trico
as we've seen in previous trailers and
stuff like that which is necessary to
reach sort of higher points and level so
again just kind of platforming gameplay
also a few light puzzles I kind of have
to get to a switch or move find some
barrels that are actually contained food
for Trico and you use that to like
incentivize him and get him to come
through the level with you so mainly
light puzzle and platforming kind of
stuff one really interesting mechanic
that I didn't expect was about halfway
through the demo I found my way into
this weird little like snow cavern and I
found a mirror shield and every time you
hold up the shield like a beam of light
shoots out and whatever it's touching
Trico will basically like shoot
lightning at so I used that to destroy a
few doors to progress through the level
yeah and so it's like kind of always
resting on the boys back as he's moving
to the level but yeah you just like hold
down the circle button and he aims it
and Trico will just like blast up for
you I thought you're gonna say it's like
when you're shining a laser on the wall
and the cat jumps at it but apparently
Trico is like a Zeus daddy lion I mean
this might be the like gameplay
interpretation of a cat chasing a laser
pointer which is a very good point Mike
good way to think about that are they
are they implying that traingle might
have more powers you don't know about
it's entirely possible I mean they get
to the end of the demo and they kind of
escape the cavern that they're in which
by the way is really beautiful it's like
grassy cave with like stone carvings in
it and what appears to be sort of a
dilapidated temple really atmospheric
really interesting setting you find like
this cavernous pool at one point you
have to swim across so it's like it's
really beautiful but at the very end
when you kind of get out of the cave and
into the world itself you hear the boys
say to try pillock oh you still can't
fly your wings are broken oh that's an
important thing when you wake up trico
doesn't trust you
trico is like wearing armor and he's
journey is like a spear sticking out of
it and you have to like pull the spear
out he roars at you and he knocks the
boy into a wall and the boys knocked
unconcious the earliest part of the game
is about like developing the trust
between these characters yeah it's it's
very cool so there's it I think you said
earlier it's still got that ambience
like you're playing a myth I think you
said yeah it feels like playing a myth
totally which is very much like share
the closets and Eko
yeah absolutely I mean you can really
tell that it's coming from you ADA I
mean it's totally that kind of tone
anybody who loved
iko iko iko iko iko but okay either one
someone in the comments will tell us
we're wrong if you played those types of
games you will immediately connect with
the tone of this game I'm quite
confident my only real concern at this
point is that it needs a little bit of
technical polish it res polish to such
as generic term but there were things
like you could see the caller that
tri-coat was wearing was like clipping
through his feathers very obviously and
other than things like awkward fall
animations that really didn't seem
believable or like camera issues when I
was trying to climb trico look at the
camera would get kind of lost so it's
that stuff isn't really major but given
that it's such an immersive game it
really kind of pulls you out of the
experience a little but fortunately
those types of issues are exactly the
kind of thing that you can fix before
launch generally if there's like design
problems or you know I've totally seen
games early on and thought like wow even
if this works it's not going to be fun
this game all of the problems that I
noticed are totally solvable so with any
luck it's gonna come together and end up
being exactly this you know beautiful
moving experience we kind of expect it
all along yeah ideally there won't be
many bugs coming really state which is
October 26th I want to say end of
October for sure I believe it's the 26 I
think that is correct so finally we will
get to play this game hopefully in
October
Scott is way ahead of us I'm pretty
jealous but anyway for more news about
the Last Guardian or any other thing
that we see here at e3 2016
stay tuned a game spot Scott see you
guys later
you